seit acht jahren ist klarer
ehrenamtliche telefonseelsorgerin in
buchen
sie kennt die unterschiedlichsten sorgen
und nöte die die anrufer an sie
herantragen nun dreht sich alles um ein
thema am schlimmsten ist diese angst vor
dem gibt es demnächst ganze
ausgangssperren und dann kommen eben
auch so die sache ja ich lebe allein die
angst vor einsamkeit wird nun immer
größer
gerade bei alleine lebenden menschen
sind gerade die ältere menschen die
sorge haben dass sie immer mehr sozial
isoliert werden wenn man davon spricht
man soll die sozialkontakte einschränken
dann haben sie die befürchtung dass sie
noch mehr alleine sind vereinsamen wir
rauskommen aus der situation der rat in
kontakt bleiben beziehungsweise kontakt
aufnehmen
aber nun eben per telefon oder per skype
miteinander kommunizieren
sie reden ich glaube es ist gut mit
anderen menschen darüber zu sprechen
sich nicht zu sehr verrückt machen zu
lassen sondern ihre im austausch
miteinander zu sein und sich gegenseitig
zu stützen in diesen zeiten besonders
diejenigen menschen nicht zu
vernachlässigen die sowieso wenig
kontakte haben vor allem weil die
vielleicht nicht aus sich selbst heraus
die kraft finden andere anzusprechen
jüngere menschen sollten nun auf ältere
zu gehen es gibt so viele einsame
pflegebedürftige alte menschen die jetzt
verunsichert sind die sich nicht mal
raus trauen vielleicht mal einen zettel
im treppenhaus oder ein zettel in den
briefkasten wichtig ist aber auch wenn
ich dann unterstützen und helfen den
abstand zu wahren
zuhören und den menschen raten viel in
kontakt zu treten per telefon oder per
soziale medien den telefonseelsorger
kommt nun eine besonders wichtige
aufgabe zu
nicht umsonst sind wir beim bundesamt
für bevölkerungsschutz mit genannt wenn
sie sagen bei den tipps
container ist eine möglichkeit auch die
telefonseelsorge anzurufen
das nehmen wir sehr ernst und haben
entsprechend technisch auch unsere
systeme so eingestellt dass wir auch
wenn mitarbeiter ausfallen werden die
krank werden wer trotzdem ein angebot
aufrechterhalten können größer als die
angst sich zu infizieren ist die angst
vor sozialer isolation berichten die
telefonseelsorge menschliches
miteinander sei nun wichtiger denn je